皆さんお早うございますというか遅くなっちゃったでおそようございますですね
すいません
まずおはようございますの後にアピにフィー
ちょっとねおじさんおかしいんじゃないと思ったちびっ子は願ってるよ
等に売ってるのかおじさん ok
いやが違うんでねいいあったいや違う
難しいけどね言い方が難しいんだけど今日はですね
まあ私の話をさせていただいて後に聞こえについて
ちょっとでもですね新しい発見のきっかけになればと思っております
お願いします
私はですね41年前に生まれましたで
生まれてすぐ実は飛火っていうものにかかってしまって全身に移りました
でもうあと1か月持たないかもしれないっていうに病院先生に言われて街と母が頑張っ
ていろんなことをやってですね一命を取り留めましたで二十歳になった時に両親から
泣かれましたこんなに大きなちょっ
なので横に大きくなってきちゃったんですよ
それじゃあ困ってるんですけども
で
そのときになぜ僕は
生き延びたんだろうと思いました
それも40になってからですねおそらくこの聞こえに関して
お前は頑張ると
それが残っているんだからお前は生きなさいと言われたなるなぁと思って
この
仕事に就いてからすごくそれを強く思うようになりました私はスピーカーによって難聴
者の人たちが聞こえやすい環境を用意するというものを開発しました
私の夢です世界中の人の伝える聞こえるをデザインしていきたいと思っています
やはりちと
祖母も軟調でした
スピーカーによって4年間研究しました
頑張りましたしかし
当時詰めて会社は全く相手にしてくれませんでした
なんでそんなも作らなきゃいけないんだというふうに貼りました
すごく悲しかったですなぜ僕が人のために頑張ろうと思っているのに会社を認めてくれ
てないんだよくわかりませんでした
そこで私は npo を立ち上げました
nb を立ち上げて聞こえに関する研究スピーカーの研究と+あ
皆さん難聴という言葉知ってますけど耳について
学校を教えてくれませんね音楽を教えてくれますしかし耳が聞こえについては全く教え
てくれないということはわかったんです
その聞こえの大切さを
お知らせするために広げたいと思って
npo を作ったんですね
しかし言われましたなぜ
あなたは聞こえるのに私たち難聴者のために頑張ってるんだ
何か企んでるんじゃないのよれました
すごく悲しかったですよ頑張れば頑張れること言われました
でも今はまったくそういうこと言われることだったりすごく嬉しいですみんな仲間です
僕の研究に対してすごく協力しくれています
でもその時思ったんです僕が研究していることは
たった一人でも僕の技術を欲しがっている人がいればこれは絶対辞めないで続けようと
思いました
それはだんだんだんだんやっていくうちに一人ではないということがわかったんですね
すごく嬉しかったです
これ皆さん見てわかりますか彼が左の彼
なんかちょっと気づきましたよねそう
こっちを受け付けていますね
皆さんは彼をですねきっと区南庁舎と言われるんですね
で彼女わかりますか何か違うなあと思うこと
そうメガネをつけています
皆さんは彼女のことを
南支社って呼ばれますか
おかしくないですか
同じ能力が低下したものを補助するための機械なのに補聴器をつける習慣たらまだ
根付いてないんです
なぜ補聴器をつけているとそういうふうに思ったのでしょうか僕はすごくそれを不思議
に思います
皆さん
今聞こえてるって事が当たり前だと思ってませんか
年齢を重ねることに視力が落ちるということはなんとなく皆さんわかっていると思い
ます
しかしながら聴力が衰えていくということは全く認識もないんですね
日本では年間3万5000人の方がいきなり
麻生人が聞こえなくなったりとか
ている方がたくさんいます
で2万3000人の方が完治することなく
難聴者になられています
突発性難聴と言います
浜崎あゆみさんも発症して非常にメディアに捉え切れました
皆さん世界にどれぐらいの難聴者の方がいらっしゃると思いますか
2015年には約5億人
10年後の2025年にはなんと9億人まで増えると言われています
やはり世界的な高齢化によってどんどんどんどん
老人が増えることで難聴者が増えると言われています私はこの聞こえにくいということ
が社会的な問題になると思っています
では日本
約1500万円の方お願いします
65歳以上の方の半数ですね約半数が当たります
日本も同じように超高齢化によって老人性の難聴がどんどん増えています
世の中の常識は
補聴器があるから大丈夫皆さんもそう思っていると思います
僕も5年前は同じようなこと思っていました
しかしそんなに簡単に解決というわけではないです
これはジャパンと行くと言われているえっと軟調だったり補聴器というアンケート調査
ですが日本における補聴器装用率はなんと14.1%
補聴器はどんどんどんどん目覚ましい技術向上しているのですがまだ14.1%です
欧米に比べて非常に低いのが湧く分かりいただけると思います
なぜ料率が低いのかこれ私は3つあると考えています
まず
つけることに対する並行ですねやはりつけると年をとったように感じる恥ずかしい
皆さんがさっき写真見て思ったように後長期放置を聞いてますねそういったことも非常
に関係しています
もう一つが聞こえはモードに戻りません部長級では
非常に機構に対して違和感があります脳が聞こえ覚えてしまっているので違いをどうし
ても許容できないんですね
最後
見えないように見えないようにしますなのでどんどんどんどんちっちゃくなりますそう
すると操作性が悪くなります
お年寄りはよくトイレに落としちゃったとかどこに行っちゃったが分からないという
非常によく言われます
聞こえにくい場合私たちに出来ることがあります
よくやっていることだと思いますああ
聞こえますかー
どうですか皆さん
やっちゃえよねー
なあそうですね聞こえすぎるうるさい n
おじさんも使えちゃうんだこれをずっとやっていると
で筆談ですねコレは確かに効果的です
耳元で話す
これも一つあると思いますしかしながら大きな音で話をすれば難聴の人に聞こえるわけ
だ
ないんですこれは画像を使って例えているんですけれども
ピンボケした画像をどんだけ大きくしても見えません
文字は認識できません
右のように文字をきちんとクリアーに出すしかないです
こうすると大きすれば見えます音も同じようにクリアにした上で大きくしないと全く
意味がないんです
難聴の方には明瞭度ということが非常に大切です
先ほどもまあありましたが耳元で囁くということは非常にです話すことはしかしながら
人間は人の症状見てコミュニケーションをとろうとします
なので表情を見せた方がいいって私は常に言っています
こちらは聴力レベルと言われているものですね
プラスマイナスゼロが人間の耳は一番いいです
a
メットチーム戦略です数が増えると耳が悪くなっていきます
まず先に正常の声を正常であることですね聞こえを聞いてみましょう
佐藤さん
方をさん
これが正常の話ですね次が
中等度難聴です
こんなにちっちゃくなりますもう一つが高度難聴
どうですか
聞こえないでしょうそう
そのぐらい聞こえずらいんですね
こうなってしまうと皆さんと会話ということが
この会話にな話にならない話が壊れている状態です
私はこの壊れた会話ですねこれを元に戻したい
なんとか改善したいと思って一つ買いましたしかしながら耳につけてもらえないという
事実があります
だから耳につけない話での方で何とかできないかということで作ったのがこのコミュ
です
これです
逆転の発想ですねまさに耳に付けなくて聞こえるということです
で
コミュニティーます
先日はグッドデザイン賞のベスト100名いただきました
話して側の方で聞こえやすい音を作り出すというものです
これあります
よっしゃでしょ
私は研究中に他社の難聴のお子さんたち
あとはがな蝶の先生たちと難聴の生徒を教える先生たちを応援しました
その中で決めたことがありますコミューンが完成したら絶対
プレゼントしたいという話をしました今おかげさまで1月31日以降の6個の方まで
寄贈が進んでいます
でもすでに20校の学校から寄贈してほしいという形で入ってます
聞こえのユニバーサルデザインを教育観でどんどんどんどん進めているところです
皆さんヘレンケラーってご存知ですか目も見えない耳も聞こえない方ですね
ヘレンケラーが言っている言葉があります
目が見えなくなると
人と物と話す
耳が聞こえなくなると人と人と話すと言っています
私が解決していきたいのは聞こえではなくて人と人とのコミュニケーションなんです
ここで一つ
僕は手紙をもらったのでお話をさせてくださいコミュを使っている方です先日お手紙を
いただきました
中谷さんこんにちは
先日の
試聴会ではありがとうございました
今まで難聴である母に大声で話をしてましたが
いつも話をするときに起こっているみたいですごくやだとあなたとは話ししたくないと
言われたことがきっかけで母との会話が減り
大変困っていました
コミュんが我が家に来てから食事でこれまでと同じように
普通に母と会話することができ母の笑顔も増えてきました
普通に会話ができることがこんなに幸せなことであるのを日々実感しています
これからも母とのコミュニケーションを大切にしていきます
込みを開発していただき本当にありがとうございました
嬉しいですね
怪しいんじゃないのって言われたから3年経ちますが凄く嬉しいですね
もうそういうことを言う人はいなくなりました
皆さんにお願いです
難聴聴覚障害っていうのは全く理解され非常に理解される
見えないんですどのぐらい聞こえないかっていうのを咲音を聞いてでくらいわかりませ
んだからこそ
おとうや言葉を伝える側が
音声コミュニケーションの大切さをもっと理解してほしいんです
一つ入ったらおじいちゃんおばあちゃんいるかもしれないですけど
聞こえにくいテレビが大きいおじいちゃんおばあちゃんがいたらねちょっと考えて
下さいおじいちゃんがこういうことを言ってたなと思って頂けると嬉しいですあとお
友達に補聴器とか人工内耳つけているお友達がいたら一扱いやすいようにしてあげて
ほしい
と思っています
最後にお願いですね難聴用の人や聴覚障害者の方と話をするときに私たちにできること
だということで
5つ挙げました
自分の声が聞き取れる大きさが確認する
このぐらいの大きさでいいかな補聴器つけたりですよこのぐらいの大きさでいいかなっ
ておいてください
あと騒がしいとを避けてください非常に雑音が多いところは補聴器が拾ってしまうので
非常に嫌がります
静かなところに移動してあげるとしてくださいあと前を向いてハッキリ口を開けて
ください
音で一人ない分資格でコミュニケーションをとろうとしますんで
口の
アタチ読信じるんですけども口を見ていますあとはマスクを外してあげてください
あと最後にきちんと伝えたいと思ってください
この人に自分の想いをちょっと伝えたいんだと思うことが非常に重要だと思っています
聞こえのユニバーサルデザインを目指して
引き続き私は頑張りますありがとうござした